Welcome to "The
Next Level," people.
I want you to say hello
to tonight's comedian.
I'm talking about my
guy, Malik S, who comes
to us from Miami, Florida.
Come on, man.
Get a guy some love.
[cheers and applause]
Good to have you.
- Good to see you, man.
- Same thing.
- I like the outfit.
- Yeah, yeah.
Let's talk about you teaching.
And I heard that
you taught, man.
Yeah, I'm a teacher, man--
English teacher.
- What grades you teach?
- Sixth and eighth grade.
Sixth and eight grade?
- Yeah.
- Get out.
Yeah, man.
Yeah.
Successful teacher?
Like, you actually--
No, not really.
Substitute teacher,
or a real teacher?
- No, a real teacher.
- A real teacher?
Yeah, for a year--
well, not a whole year.
We went to spring break.
You know you get that week off?
I ain't going back.
You ain't going
back after that?
Public school?
Oh, god, I didn't go back.
Public school.
They gave me a week
to think it over.
I was like, fu--
The crazy thing is, you know,
spring break is kind of, like--
like, April.
School ends in, like, May, June.
So I had enough
sick time to take
off for the rest of the year.
You said, I'm not coming back.
So I really still
had a job, but I
was just like, ah, I'm sick.
OK, I saw this picture,
and I just want I want to--
I want to ask the
people what they think.
I'm gonna show you
guys what Malik looked
like when he was teaching.
This is-- this is--
this is what he looked like.
That's exactly
what I looked like.
That's what he looked
like when he was teaching.
But this is-- this in
Miami, Florida, though.
And this is 2003--
you got to think, like,
that was the look.
Yeah, but how-- how
did you go from here to--
to there?
Like, what--
Well, 'cause-- 'cause
they kept backing up.
So-- so it was like, I was
going have convertible dreads.
So I'll just say, you know what?
Cut 'em off.